so much in a circle well so so we're
going to bit of a problem in that like
this is this is a relation right it's a
relation so I can think about the two
halves if you've got the top semicircle
right well for the entirety of its
domain it looks concave down to me and
by the way we can we can prove this
pretty like it's not hard
think about this let's take like what's
the equation of a circle
give me an easy one okay so I trade you
well here's the unit circle right that's
the whole thing that's the top and the
bottom to consider is I just want to do
one part at a time because a relation
you've got two driven news everywhere
that's not very helpful okay so how will
they turn that into a semi circle what
will I do to it I want to take a square
root now what I want to do is it will
help if I have because most functions
have y as a subject it's a good lease if
that you put something in you get
something out okay so this is still both
sides right if I take the square root
that gives me plus or minus and now you
can see there's the top half the plus
half and it's the - which is the bottom
half let's just think about the top one
for a second the top so that's the one
that I'm just drawing over here that
said axis but you get that's the square
root of 1 minus x squared how do I write
that in such a way that I could actually
differentiated or any next form right so
I've got this 1 minus x squared to the
power of 1/2 I can differentiate this I
have chain rule I know how to do this
what's going to happen okay well do the
inside and then we'll do the outside is
that ok so the inside is 1 minus x
squared its derivative is minus 2x okay
and then I do the outside the outside
it's something to the power of 1/2 so
I'm going to multiply by the power and
then I'm going to reduce the power by
one he's comfortable with
is that okay fine I can I can tidy up a
little bit right let's see here - X I'm
going to leave this in index form the
reason I'm going to leave it in index
form is because I need a different shape
video is that okay right so this was
let's do the second review now this is
not quite as nice because I'm going to
need to do quotient sorry product and
chain rule but that's okay that's okay
we can do it let's think about this
we'll call this okay one step at a time
it's a product right so this is V u -
plus you be nice you care with that then
over the while since we've done these
questions okay we just don't do it V is
just this whole thing okay 1 minus x
squared to the power negative 1/2 what's
you - okay I've got you there it's just
minus X okay this is this is the fun
part now at least at least I've actually
done something just like this a second
ago and so this just not as bad as it
looks
V - all right I'm gonna do the inside
which is minus 2x and then I'm gonna do
the outside which is running out of
space here I'm gonna multiply by a power
which is negative 1/2 and then I'm going
to reduce the power by 1 which is 1
minus x squared to power of minus 3 on -
now I know it looks gross that's okay it
was just the first step for remember all
I'm interested in is what can this time
upper cavity well anything it was sign
that's all I need okay so let's tidy up
this disaster okay what am I getting out
the front
it's just it's just this guy right you
see that was my V you - is that okay so
that looks like minus one over the
square root of 1 minus X said okay
what's hanging on the end how many keys
do I have I've got one two three
negatives so I'm going to get a negative
okay
I've got a two and I've got a half so
that cancels and then I'm gonna into
this so that gives me an X square what
happens for this that's one minus x
squared x squared it's on the
denominator no I actually could write it
like that I could write it as this which
may actually help me do you see that's
the path 302 said okay there's the one
and there's a half and that's actually
not a bad idea because I have on these
two fractions here right and I actually
want them to come together because I
want to go at the side of the whole
thing okay see you're gonna be in this
fashion now okay that's right to get the
fractions together I need the same
denominator tonight okay that's the
denominator here so don't the
denominators the same all I do is 1
minus x squared 1 minus X square are you
comfortable with that boy I should not
have started my working that look okay
he's so now I've got these two fractions
hey I can put these together I can
totally put these together don't get
intimidated okay that minus one times
that he's going to give me x squared
minus one that's the first fraction yep
yep take away the second fraction over
some Gerstein this guy carried up
what's up man you ready okay be careful
be careful be careful on the denominator
you have to be a bit careful with this
thing this is the power of three or two
we're not used to dealing with that but
that's okay remember this is a
semicircle right I rubbed it off but
where is this semicircle again where
does it exist between negative 101 right
now in this restricted domain okay tell
me what's the smallest this could
possibly get can XE quote for instance
let's do this simply take an X equal one
okay sure
let's think about this there's a few
things happening here right yeah really
you got this now alright Lee Jung the
graph itself the graph itself is
continuous it better be it's a circle it
exists there okay but even before I get
to this which is the second derivative
right boy by the way did it simplify did
you expect it to simplify that much
presently um even when you got to the
first derivative here's the first
derivative the first derivative doesn't
exist at that point we just mentioned
why not okay firstly because if I if I
put in x equals one minute I'm on the
denominator already
but more importantly geometrically
because it's a freaking circle the
tangent here is vertical so you have no
gradient it can't have a gradient so
that's why it doesn't exist so if the
first derivative doesn't exist then you
can forget about the same but okay now
even before I get to zero right I kind
of know what's happening is you're just
to the left of one okay because I have a
gradient bit I have a stepping over you
did okay so I put in some tiny number
like 0.9 no no no no no nine
okay when you square that what's gonna
happen to it you'll be a well if it's
just point 909 it's actually pretty
close to one so when you square it it
will still be close to one but a little
bit smaller a little bit smaller is that
okay
you know what - that is it positive or
negative it's positive it's a very small
positive number so therefore when you do
this it's still positive in other words
all of that to argue my denominator is
positive okay I can make the same
argument when I go this way because it's
an even function okay it's an even
function so therefore you can rehearse
this whole thing when you put a negative
you the same thing will happen it will
still be the denominator it will still
be positive but my numerator is negative
I always have a negative on the top I
always have a positive on the bottom
that means the whole thing is always
which means the whole thing so I'm
looking at that semicircle yeah okay now
here's the thing right if I repeated
this process and I looked at the bottom
part right what would change everything
would be exactly reverse so this guy
yeah I would take the negative case all
right so then my derivative would be
negative which would mean my second
review would also be negative of that
all right so it would just be one on one
- so then you'll have positive I'm
positive
because I can't I know geometrically I
can't get anything meaningful on this I
can see other otherwise I'm just going
to get both yeah I'm concave I've been
down everywhere well that's nice but
it's not meaningful okay yeah the domain
is actually an important part of is
because how do I put in X is greater
than one right what happens well this is
going to become 1 minus some bigger
number this thing will be negative I'm
in trouble
right the concavity will be well the
concavity will change right and so yeah
the restricted domain is actually a
crucial part which is why I didn't know
ok